Okay.
Hey, what's going on?
It's Bill Burr and It's time for the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
January 16th, 2070 what's going on?
how are you?
How are you everybody and happy, um,
Luther king day to everybody you know,
happy Martin Luther King Day, you know, for, for those you are,
that means some to you for those you just, yeah. You know,
it's another day off edge.
Just like when Georgie over our abies birthday in February.
Did we get those days off? Um, the two whities there,
the two whities in February, I believe it's in February. Right.
During black history month,
you still got a shoehorn George Washington day and Lincoln's birthday in there?
Correct. Then you got another yt and why? Hey,
you got another yt and a
was saint Patrick a you pasty faced fucking son of a bitch.
Ya Right. Then in April you got uh Oh,
here comes Peter cottontail hopping down the body trail. Right.
With his own little white bunny. Yes. Right now what do you got?
You got in May. Who is that? Is that April go today? I don't know.
I run out of somewhere around there. Those are weird. The dog days of the year.
It's like fucking, you know, a flag day.
Then I always get memorial day and Labor Day. Memorial Day is is May,
right? Memorial Day, Memorial Day is in May.
We recognize all the veterans, you know,
that fought for your freedom so you can sit around, eat fucking dip and shit,
right.
Changing all your fucking VCR tapes over to fucking DVD days and then to a
little fucking stick, whatever the fuck it is you do that day. Right.
Um, and you got July 4th so everybody can go around and fucking, you know,
trade stories about their uncle that blew his fucking fingers off cause he never
got married. He was trying to impress his nephews and nieces. Right.
You're so cool. Lucky Jimmy.
All right. See you see that right there son? You see that right there?
That's why I told you y'all could. Jimmy ain't no fucking good title. Mom.
Quit your cry. Well I don't want to hear it.
No more weight going over uncle Jimmy's. Okay.
It's over there with loose fucking women and just play with them. Fire crackers.
Right. So that's July 4th, then August, August is kind of like a month.
It's up for grabs. No Jewish holidays. No. Hey,
remember Jesus did this for you. What did he say to him? Muslims,
what do you got? You got some that month. How about you?
Buddhist Buddhists don't give a shit, right? They're like, hey man,
like every day for everybody. And it's just like,
as long as we're sitting around and feeling the breeze,
that's what I'm trying to be, you know,
I'm trying to be that person today was to be my 10th day in a row to a meditate,
but I didn't,
I woke up late and I had to take my lady over to the doctors and um,
and I just, I just got up late. Yeah. I had this fucking weird ass dream too.
And this weird dream where I was when on my back porch I was watching these
helicopters flying in formation and dive bomb in my neighborhood.
And I was like, what the fuck did they do in that for?
And then one of them lost control and I had this weird view from my house that
I've never had before. And it was just basically the cockpit, you know,
and the engine dead part in the skids, no main rotor, no tail,
no tail road and nothing else.
And for some reason it wasn't tipping over and falling to the ground like a
fucking trashcan or most likely inverting.
It just fucking,
it just went straight and it sort of landed and I ran down there,
I was in my underwear cause you were always in your underwear, in your dreams,
right? You never have your pants on. It's so fucking weird.
This all always with mine, there's always that level of humiliation.
No matter what's going on, I can't find my pants. Right. Um,
anyways, so the fucking thing lands. So I run up and then I'm thinking like,
wait a minute, do I want to see the carnage that is in there?
And then all these people showed up with like cell phone cameras and stuff and I
was standing there in my underwear and I ran home. That was that. They go,
there's your dream to interpret for the week. All right.
Cause I'm not going to therapy anymore because I spent enough fucking money,
you know, with somebody daydreaming with the goddamn notebook. Right?
And none of them ever look like that brought on the Sopranos. Let's be honest.
Right? Um, yeah. So I started, I woke up late.
All right? So I need to fucking relax. Quiet my mind.
Make it more of a still pond. Whenever a rock falls into the pond,
what happens? The waters ripple. Yes.
The waters ripple. And if too many rocks fall in, what happens?
There starts to be a storm.
And this is what I want you to pay attention to today during today's meditation
is your brain is still pond.
Okay,
well, can you hear it? This screaming,
watery death of 1200 passengers going under the water of,
of your mind. Sorry, I lost it. I don't know what the fuck I was talking about.
Anyways. Um, I also, my apologies this week,
apology number one,
I own apology to the fucking Atlanta Falcons.
I owe an apology to the Houston Texans.
I owe an apology to Meryl Streep.
Evidentaly going into Twitter according to one person. All right,
let's start with the Seattle Seahawks, right? You know,
I thought those were going to be the dirty,
filthy stinken disease carry and birds that were going to win that gang.
I said last week, and I, I kind of quote,
you know who got off easy this weekend,
the New England patriots and the Seattle Seahawks because the cowboys and the
packers are going to beat the fuck out of each other and the Steelers and the
fucking chiefs are gonna beat the shit out of each other, right?
And then all we gotta do is play the winner.
Okay.
That these two teams were just going to waltz to the AFC and NFC championship
game as if that is a given. Well, let's start with the Atlanta Falcons.
I picked the wrong dirty Burt's a very impressive win,
and I know Seattle fans are going to be like, we had some major injuries,
which they did coming into the game and then they lost another guy.
I understand that. Okay, I totally understand that. Seattle fans.
You're 100% right. Christ.
You can hear you cry in from here. Your stadium is so loud.
Oh my God though. Seattle. See they're so fucking lie.
I'm so sick. I ESP and fucking like just ignoring that entire fact.
They just don't. They know what it is. You know what? As they can't,
they have the ability to separate themselves from the truth.
That's what I really respect from ESPN is they can just separate themselves with
truth and just go for the fucking money.
They don't give a shit about what's right or none of them give a fuck.
They just say in shit to say shit.
So idiots like me get upset and yell at their fucking TV and keep watching.
And then what do they do? They get some more habit dash theory, right?
They date, date, you know, they, they get,
they get a bigger fucking whatever the fuck it is thereafter over there.
New Tie Tech. I don't know.
I don't know what motivates people that want to sit around in suits talking
about sports. Why do they wear suits? By the way,
can anybody explain that to me?
Why are they all sitting there like there on meet the press when they talking?
I just, I don't fucking understand it. You know, and it's contagious.
Talk and standing in a fucking suit.
Talking about a sports is so fucking contagious.
Ben Roethlisberger,
Ben Big Ben. I ain't wearing no fucking helmet when I ride a motorcycle,
showed up dressed, dare I say dressed to the fucking eye.
He looked like 1 million bucks from the fucking neck. Doubt.
His suit was fucking sharp. He had a pocket square that tie the shirt,
the whole fucking thing. He was killing it. Okay. Oh,
Jay would have gone off this a second time if he wore that fucking suit yet on
Sunday. However, from the neck up, he just looked at him going like,
this guy crushes a 12 pack while eating. All right. A French fries.
I know he does. Okay. Why? You know, you know what? He looked like?
He looked like a guy.
A kid looked like a convicted drunk driver trying to get his license back.
Now you promise me you're not gonna do this again? Yes, your honor. Absolutely.
I've seen the error of my ways, you know, it's still all puffy.
I'm fucking with you. I Love Ben, Ben Roethlisberger, but seeing him in a suit,
you know, he was, he was all grown up. I'm proud of him. Um,
so my apologies. The Atlanta Falcons,
and I'm not going to know anybody's fucking names. Okay.
I don't know anybody's names. I know Julio Jones and I know, uh, Sherman,
you know who Julio Jones made look, he made him look, I wouldn't,
I would never say regular because Sherman is the shit.
He made him look he a little bit and I've never seen him do that cause that guy
still shuts down his part of the fucking field. All right.
And he made him look a kind of a, you know, he's guy's pretty good.
He's got some pretty good footwork there. Um, and also I thought he, uh,
when cab chancellor came up where he usually just fucking lays the fucking
lumber. Julio Jones dropped his shoulder, absorbed the shit. And Dare I say,
I'm not going to say he put cam on his back, but it,
it was not an issue that cam hit him and that really surprised me. And um,
I don't know. I don't know any the fucking names.
I'll say the Atlanta's fucking running back. Whatever the fuck his name is. Uh,
the one who doesn't pretend to eat cereal, whenever he fucking gets a few yards,
that's the cowboys one. He gets up, you know, you know Jesus,
you ever seen a guy campaign and harder to get a lift in soup ad, you know,
is that guy who used to be on the giants and then did the show at that little
cutie pie in the morning and then for some reason left that show to be one of 19
with the guy who used to run fucking a Clinton's campaign.
Is it George Stephanopoulos on a morning show right now?
Like that guy's got to be on like what the fuck?
What happened and what do I, 25 fucking years ago,
I was dealing with the Russians
now fucking sitting here on pancake Wednesday acting like I'm excited about this
shit. Sit on this fucking couch.
You know what the worst parts of those shows are as the way they decorate the
coffee table? You know,
I can't imagine trudging in there every fucking day to do that show of like,
what fucking monkey suit are they putting you in today? You know,
girls have to have their Sassy. I'm a morning person. Outfits, you know,
the guys have to have that. Uh, you know, I'd show up in a, you know,
I turned the whole fucking paycheck over to,
you wouldn't pull some Angela's ashes shit and go to the pub instead.
They got to have that fucking look. You know what I mean? Um,
why did stray hand leave that show? Cause that little cutie pie,
what the fuck is her name? I said, I want to real life. She's fucking smoking,
smoking hot right now. It was just the two of them. They had a great time,
right? She come out on his shoulder like a parakeet. He threw the monologue,
she giggled alarm in. They had the whole fucking thing.
It was just the two of them, just the two of them,
and if for some reason he leaves that show,
Michael Strahan, arguably one of the most successful people, you know,
people look at Mark Cuban and they go, Amy, here's a guy you know,
he didn't have any fucking money. He starts some internet company.
He makes a zillion dollars that he buys an NBA team. Great.
He starts go bald, he gets the fuck in here, plugs. He goes to Vegas,
he's at a rave. You don't know where this guy's going.
He's got his own fucking jet. Everybody thinks this is the guy.
This is the next fucking Bill Gates Guy. He's on shark tank.
Okay? He's having people coming in who could barely afford the guests and their
lawnmower and he's listening to their ideas and then owning them and then taking
them and not giving it. You know? But you know what, guys like that too, right?
I don't know why I'm picking on this guy. He's just funny to me. Right. Um,
I'll go have this. Everybody thinks he's the next Bill Gates.
And meanwhile you got Michael Stray here. Okay.
Who came up from the hard streets or somewhere? I don't know where he came from,
but I know he's African American, so I know his streets weren't soft. Right.
What was the last time you saw an African American make it and they,
and they said they did not come from hard streets,
that he came from soft streets. You never see that.
You do not stay or no soft streets on that side of the fucking fence.
So we gave from the heart streets.
I'm not aware of where are we going to put that guy.
He doesn't seem like a New York guy. He seems like a Pennsylvania Dude.
I Dunno where the fucking kid, the hard streets of Harrisburg, Pennsylvania.
Allentown. I don't know where the fuck he came from. Whatever.
He fucking makes it. Okay. He becomes a fucking superstar,
right? He deals with Tiki Barber and whatever the fuck he was trying to do,
you know, throwing the ball low all over the carpet retires early.
They get him out of the way. It goes into the super bowl. Now follow back up.
Fucking gets the sack record. Right. You know,
and his last one of course was the most impressive, which bread farmers run on.
That was the precursor to the bud fumble. It's the exact same body motion,
except he didn't run into a giant offensive lineman's ass.
He just came in and just sort of laid down. All right then,
if I remember correctly, where the fuck did they go?
They went somewhere on the road and one,
then they went into green bay and one and they went into Dallas and one I might
have those two flip flops.
And then they went to the Superbowl play the eight New England patriots and they
fucking kick the shit out of them on the offensive line.
One on the last fucking play of the game. Okay. And uh,
when's her fucking Superbowl? And then you think that's it now? And he goes, oh,
he's a broadcast to toe. He's fucking killing it. Ah,
but you know a lot of guys done that hour. We long did it. Terry Bradshaw dead.
Fucking OJ Simpson dead it. Everybody fucking did it. Right?
That's just what you do.
If you can actually fucking talk about the game and you can put on a goddamn
suit, then he does the unprecedent. Okay.
A visionary move that not even Mark Cuban could come up with.
He decides that, you know what, I am the,
I am the next logical choice to take over for fucking Regis Philbin.
Right? I mean,
I did a whole bit about Arnold Schwarzenegger one time about all of his
accomplishments. I would put, I would put the straight hand right there. Okay.
And then he fucking, what does he do? What does he do? He gets,
everything's going great for whatever fucking reason he decides to join the
Partridge family on mother fucking morning show.
It's gonna be the same shit standing around watching somebody cook something,
right? Talking about us.
Some fucking person just had the a hundred and fifth birthday.
Why would you want to be over there with all of those fucking ass heads?
You know, all of those different personalities.
You know someone's going to be a cunt, right?
You could have just stayed at your other show.
Have you ever heard somebody waste more time talking about something that nobody
gives a fuck about in your life? I don't know what the hell that was.
That was 10 minutes on Michael Strahan. All right. Um, probably like six,
but it felt like 50. Um,
so my apology to the dirty birds down in Atlanta,
I apologize for disrespecting your team.
I didn't realize how good you guys were.
I wrote you guys off again at the beginning of the game when I heard you had the
, the, you know, you scored the most points,
but we're the worst in the league in the red zone. I'm like, well,
the game's over.
Okay,
the game is fucking over.
So you run up a bunch of points during the regular season against 90% of the
teams that are not gonna make the playoffs. So that's out the window.
And then meanwhile,
you couldn't stop 100% of these cons in the red zone right there.
That's a formula for disaster. And what did they do? They went out,
they beat Seattle so bad. There wasn't one point.
Okay.
During that game, I think on the first drive I saw Pete Carroll one time when,
Woo.
That was it. That was it. Oh Man.
I love PKO man. He's a fucking great coach. You know,
he was fucking pissed when they lost. Oh, he was fucking pissed.
Can you imagine his family dog?
He seems like would have a little one too of just standing the equivalent in the
corner.
Pete walking around with his ridiculously white brand new socks,
walking across this carpeted floor as what he seems like to me. Right.
Has on his fucking docker PJ's.
Yeah.
That dog just gets a little too close. You know,
I don't understand why we didn't shut up daddy pence and fucking thing goes
flying into the fireplace. Um, anyways,
he's probably a cat person who knows. And my apology to the Texas used Houston,
Texas who without JJ fucking in and a rookie quarterback hon with the New
England Patriots for, uh, for three and a half fucking quarters. Um,
yeah, I was not impressed with us. I don't think, uh, any Patriot fan was, uh,
we'll see. We'll see. I hope that's not, I think,
I'm just hoping our offensive line had a bad game member just had a bad fucking
game. If you're going to have a bad game,
you might as well do it against the team that's missing their best offensive
player and as a brand new guy, quarterback. So maybe we got away with one.
I have no fucking idea.
All I know is we're playing Pittsburgh next week and I have no fucking
confidence in that despite the fact Pittsburgh, you know,
I don't know what they did. Like they, they kicked six field goals,
which is essentially, you know,
I don't know
if you just went on field goes,
you might as well have out there on like those figure skates, you know,
dressed up like Yogi bear or some shows like some ice capades shits,
but they did it, you know, they beat Kansas City.
I didn't see one second of the game.
I watched the beginning of the Dallas Green Bay game and then my wife wanted to
go to the movies. So I took her to the movies and I'm like, all right,
I'm recording this game. Let's record it. The fucking Steelers Kansas City game.
I saw hidden fucking fag and then I came back. Right.
Am I go right? You know, my wife's taken a bath. Everything's fucking cool.
I go to pop on the Green Bay Dallas game and I didn't fucking recorded.
Let me say it again.
I didn't fucking recorded it was [inaudible]
sounded like an insane half and ad fucking hats off to that fucking do Crosby.
Who I'm telling you right now. That was some Adam Finna Terry Shit.
I never even seen Terry hit that many 50 yarders in one fucking game.
Forget about hitting one, get an iced and then he's got to kick it again.
That guy kicked like 200 yards in field goals in like four attempts or some shit
like that. Um, that's the kind of guy that's the kind of guy right there.
You gave me a little drill again,
that's kind of guy when your championship right there.
Cause all you got fucking uh, Aaron Rogers, all he's got now,
all you've got gotta do is just get your clothes and old twinkle tellers comes
running out with balls the size of the fucking stadium.
It gives them the old right there, Fred right there. No big deal.
Do you realize how much fucking ass he got after that game? Even in Dallas,
you know those Dallas women with their fucking botox and the same amount of
makeup as an 80 year old who can't admit that she's old. You know,
they all came running out right? Took their hats off, take them boots off.
You know they all drop to the knees and their designer fucking Jordache jeans.
Yeah. You ever been to Dallas? This is, this day is so far behind in the styles.
You won't even think that there's the internet anymore.
They all dress like Dallas is still on TV. The TV show, you know
[inaudible] I'm not saying they'd brought, they don't really do that,
but the through line of that is still,
there is a lot of Larry Hagman in that city with a dash of dead JFK.
That is Dallas. And there's a lot of shiny fucking four door pickup trucks,
you know, I don't know who they're driven by, but you know,
I think you've got to get on the outskirts to get to the [inaudible] that got
them longhorns walking and stopping around in the back.
And my apologies to Meryl Streep.
Evidently somebody had a hissy fit on the fucking Twitter telling me that I am a
typical, what did he say?
Postmodern cynic or I just criticized and I offered no solutions,
which is hilarious to me. It's like, okay, so I'm in your world,
Meryl Streep and myself, uh,
should be coming up with problems, uh, problem solving things.
And you would say, I just took 20. The guy back goes,
I just saw him as a comedian making fun of Shit.
I didn't know it was a postmodern Sinek.
Yeah.
Some people,
the level of credit that they give people who don't even watch the news,
it's just fucking beyond me.
I had to go to summer school every year of high school except sophomore year
because my teacher hooked me up with a d minus and my senior year I just didn't
give a fuck and didn't go, you know, what are you gonna do? I'm done. Self.
I'm a loser. All right. I am on my bio.
I'm on my way. Applebee's
wash dishes. Thank you very much. All right. So, um,
I know way too much football. How about some hockey? Just one quick mention.
All right.
Did anybody see Adam McQuaids fight when they fucking against Nashville?
Jesus Christ. Jesus Christ.
I don't know the name of the guy who fought,
but that guy's got fucking balls bigger than my giant head.
Anybody who's got the balls that dropped the gloves,
I'm not shitting on the guy. I just added McQuaig that fucking guy can fight.
Um, agents. Like what Gash, what Gash,
what goes in and the guy ducked down and he fucking didn't.
I thought it was an uppercut that when I watched in s a m slow motion.
I think it might've been a hook. I Dunno. It just reminded me in a very,
very junior way of when Clark Gillies fucking broke that guy's face.
He was pounding this guy so bad,
the guy just ducked down and right as he ducked down,
Gillies just went up or cod and his fist was big enough to cover the guy's whole
face. And it was like,
it was like he punched a glass coffee table and this guy just went,
he like straight down like when they pull a building, you know. Um,
and the first time I noticed that that guy could fight with, uh,
he beat the fuck out a rap.
Ralphie Torres when he was playing with the Phoenix coyotes.
I'll have links to those fights, but that's, that's our,
I guess he is our enforcement now.
And what's great is he's a fucking unbelievable defenseman too. So, uh,
that's it. Celtics. What are we doing? We're doing what we always do.
We beat the pretenders and we can't beat the contenders. That's our deal. Ed.
A enough sports. All right, let me, uh,
should I read a little bit of advertising for you? Huh? But evidently,
I guess you have to apologize to Meryl Streep. You know,
cause I guess I preach also on my podcast,
which is the same as hijacking and award show, right?
Did Meryl Street once say, Hey, I'm a fucking more on, what do I know?
I don't think she did. All right. Oh, Billy street.
Okay, here we go. Let's read a little bit. Oh Jesus. Here we go. Matt, up, up,
up beyond the swearing in fucking Trump by
[inaudible] makes you want to take a dump. But though,
fuck it worries you ball will be soft.
They don't care that you got a lot of shit in the back.
It has a trap door that you open up like old long underwear. Well Jesus.
All right, the Valentine's Day gift. Oh, this Valentine's Day.
Give a gift that they can unwrap again
and again. Matching underwear from me on these now Jesus.
Who the fuck was all right? Valentine's is near and it's time. It's a,
it's a goat in, in his go time. Sorry for thoughtful gift hunting.
Any words that have a dash in it? Like they're together. Like it's a team. Like,
I'm like a rookie quarterback. I can't, I, you know,
I just look at my number one receiver.
I can't check down to the next guy and I just stumble over it.
It's go time anywhere. Any, I guess you put a dash there.
Yeah,
cause I'd be like, it's go time.
It's go time for thoughtful gift hunting me on these has you covered with
limited edition also a dash matching pairs of undies for you and yours has
Valentine's Day. Got Your stumped. Now it doesn't. I don't, I don't,
I don't give into the crazy emotion of much like everybody trying to get me
freaked out that I'm having a kid any minute now. All right.
Forget the cliches and give a gift that looks great.
Feels great and will make everyone happy. Me undies.
Fancy dinners and chocolate lasts the night.
Flowers last a week. Oh, shots fired.
It's Sherry's berries in 1-800-FLOWERS.
Mandy's getting all Gangsta rap here in the fucking beginning of the year this
year.
Give the gift of looking great and feeling great every day with the world's most
comfortable fucking underwear. Heads up. Valentine's days.
February 14th case you haven't noticed every fucking year of your life.
Why are they saying that? Like it's fucking groundhog day. You know like Easter,
how that moves around. You know, February, December 25th is Jesus's birthday.
Happy Birthday to Jesus, right? Valentine's days,
February 14th but don't panic. Get your heart on. Get your heart on.
I get it and show some love with me on these matching undies.
Where are you getting panties? His and her panties.
This is getting freaky here beyond these other perfect gift for you and your
Valentine. This hell holiday.
They're unbelievably soft and come and limited edition prints me undies knows
that your special, someone deserves a special fabric,
which is why their underwear is made exclusively out of modal, modal,
a fabric with a touch three times softer than cotton beyond.
He says this is so fucking creepy. Three times softer than cotton.
Come on, everybody get in the van beyond,
he says a special limited edition Valentines, Valentines undies,
which means you and your Valentine's can match and yet it's as cute as it
sounds. It's sounds creepy. It sounds creepy.
I'm like, oh,
it's either going to be really like masculine looking or really feminine looking
or you're just saying it's the same print, you know?
So you know who's going to buy these fun fucking underwear?
The kinds of people that have four kids and all name them by the first
continent. These are my kids,
Larry Laurie lean up and they Louie
[inaudible].
Why do people do that?
And if for some reason you and me undies aren't a perfect match,
they you your money back and let you keep the first pair.
There's no refund on a bad fancy dinner. Dude,
you're in your fucking house, Larry, and you've got four kids.
What? Know what Larry, Larry, Larry,
Lina, I didn't, was I calling you stuff yellow, your beat dad,
call to action. Uh, they offer free shipping.
And for a limited time listeners to this, this station, this station,
this is the copy that give to the radio guys,
he can kick me a little nod listeners to this podcast.
Get 20% off their first order,
but you have to go to [inaudible] dot com slash burr with the Mandy's better day
guarantee. You have nothing to lose. So don't wait any longer.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash bear right now for 20% off your first daughter
that me and he's done clubs led for if you're matching underwear,
I'm going to go out on a limb and say the gayest of gay couple.
I don't even know that you guys would even do that.
Would you even be that festive?
Are Gay people festive or is that just a stereotype that Hollywood is spoon
feeding to America and that's what needs to stop dollar shave club.
Everybody Dollar Shave Club always gives you a close snoop shave and you can't
beat the convenience of the price.
You don't have to choose between settling for a cheap bag is shitty.
Disposable razors are paying out the fucking nose for a raise it with the laser
pointer and 17 blades. It's awful.
Then dollar shave club broke onto the scene with the smarter choice.
Before Dollar Shave Club, there was no middle ground.
It was either shave a with your fucking girlfriends,
things she did her legs with, cut up your fucking face.
So he spent a zillion dollars. Um, now you get those free ones at the gym,
which felt like shaving with a piece of glass there or pay a fortune for the
latest. Okay, I'm just skipping around.
The copy of Dollar Shave Club is the best of both worlds.
You get the premium shape quality at the disposable shave price, right?
It's like buying a Cadillac for five bucks.
If you haven't tried dollar shave club yet, you're missing out.
It's an amazing shave and affordable price. If you haven't figured that out yet,
what the 20 paragraphs of fucking copy,
there's no smarter choice on the market right now.
They're giving away a one month trial of any of their razors for only a dollar
with free shipping. And after that, it's just a few bucks a month. See that?
Like a drug dealer. If they gave you a little taste of the crack,
then you're hooked. Then you're stealing VCRs. There's no longterm commitments,
no hidden fees, and you can cancel whenever you want.
Get your your $1 trial@dollarshaveclub.com slash bar.
That's dollar shave club.com/. Burn. Alright, there's two more reads. And, uh,
I'm seeing double, so I'm going to take a fucking break here. All right. Um,
okay. What do I want to talk about here? Oh, you know, I was watching the, uh,
speaking of Cadillacs, Elvis Presley,
um, I was watching the Meekum autumn autumn autos.
Wait, I'm trying to open this fucking blind. Jesus Christ.
Come on for fuck sakes. How hard does this have to be day ago? Shit.
A little light on the, um, I was watch one of those Mika, um,
automobile auctions and uh, I got to tell you, I'm fucking over the muscle cars.
I love muscle cars like any other red blood America in it,
and it red blood and Bug and American. I like those fucking cars,
but every fucking wants the same thing. We got some mopar power coming up.
Of course she dope. Oh, really? Does it have a Hemi?
Is that a Shelby? It's the same. And what it basically is,
is that it's the same fucking like 20 muscle cars.
What are you going to have? What are you going to have?
You know what you're going to have. You're going to have a Shelby Mustang,
you're going to have the tried powered fucking corvette, right?
You're going to have the fucking, you're gonna have a GTO. Ah,
you're going to have a fucking a,
all that Mopar fucking Hemi shit that I never got into. I was never a Chrysler,
dodge guy, Plymouth guy. And I liked the Barracuda. I,
they're going to have a fucking a challenger.
They going to have a charger or they're gonna have a super B.
They're going to have the fucking,
whatever that z 28 was that they only made fucking 10 of them.
They're going to have one of those.
It's the same fucking cars over and over again. And meanwhile,
here's my question, why the fuck are all the trucks?
Do you know where the fuck are all the trucks?
Occasionally a truck will come across trucks, a coolest shit.
And where's all those great old man gangster cars? You know,
like the fucking, my favorite one of all time,
the 1967 Cadillac.
Eldorado that fucking car it just go fuck yourself.
I love that fucking car. That's the kind of car, you know what I mean?
That you drive when you read the post divorce or you were smart enough never to
get married. Okay.
And you're successful and you're just fucking driving around and you got,
you got, you got, you got stable a bitches and you know,
they don't give a fuck about you. You don't give a fuck about them. Yeah.
They pay girlfriends. That's the fucking car you have. You know,
and this is the thing. And rather than secretly being lonely and empty inside,
you're actually fulfilled because you own that car.
You are the closest thing to the most interesting man in the world. You know,
that stay thirsty. My friends, you ever seen a woman in his life? You see women
whim men in his fucking life. You know what I mean?
You never see him at a fucking dance recital with his fucking rug rats.
Um, anyways, I fucking loved that car.
I the most gangster fucking car. And then I also liked the 65, uh,
uh, Jesus Christ with the clamshell fucking opened,
the headlights said Buick Riviera. Okay. And, um,
at some point that might be my next,
I drive the Jag into the ground. By the way, I sold my Prius today,
add that fucker for nine years, man. [inaudible] um, that's great.
I never did that before. I never sold it to just a person.
I always traded them in. And this time I actually sold it to a person.
Got The title, did the whole thing, felt like Richard Rawlings, you know,
what does he say when he physio get chefs? Right.
Except it was a Prius and I didn't build it. Other than that, I was just like,
I'm speaking of which the debut of gas monkey garage is tonight.
And rumor has it that the bearded wonder Aaron is leaving the fucking show,
which is, uh, you know, that's like Eddie van Halen,
Leven van Halen or David Lee Roth leaving. I mean, it's, it's, it's, I am,
you know, there's a lot of,
I'm interested to see what they do with this one. Hi, how are you going to,
uh, how are you going to make up for that guy? Jesus Christ. Um,
but I'll be tuning in. I'll be tuning in cause that's,
that's all the shows out there. That's the best one out there.
And there's so many shows that rip that fucking show off and try to capture that
formula. That's the best one out there. And I love the shit that they built.
Speaking of trucks last season, they were saying, you know what?
We're all truck guys. We're all truck guys and I'm yelling at the TV.
Well then fucking make some more trucks.
I remember that they made that one for Casey.
They can count on one hand they made the one for Casey. They made that, uh,
they made the Chevy.
Especially if you get those ones that had the two tone taint, two tone taint.
Jesus Christ. Two tone, two tone paint.
I don't know if I can finish this idea to tone tape. You know what that is?
That's your taint is the normal,
your normal flesh color and somebody tries to kick you in the balls from behind
and they miss and you get a black and blue mark on part of your tape.
Then what you have is a two tone. Tane. Alright, two tone pate.
Um, they, and they did last year. What did they do?
They did a like a 1948 or 49 Chevrolet.
Uh, and they just went all out what the fucking thing. And uh,
it was, it was absolutely fucking, it was, it was, it was just amazing.
It's amazing what they do in that show. And I wish I had this skills. Um,
who knows? Someday maybe someday I'll fucking,
okay.
I have the time to find a fucking 67 a Cadillac.
Eldorado dragged that fuck around in somebody's backyard and have somebody like
that build a thing for me. I'm going to those guys too. I would drive it.
I saw one on a, I hate people to get those fucking cars and don't drive them.
I got one for you if you want to look this up right now. All right.
Look up 1965 Cadillac Eldorado $45,000.
This fucking guy,
he's got the best looking one I think I've ever seen has like the,
somebody did a whole body off restoration on it as like fucking 33 miles.
He got it when it had like seven miles on it and then now he's selling it with
33, and it's just like, why would you,
I would drive that fucking thing to 200,000 miles.
Unbelievable fucking car. Um,
but uh, the only part I will warn you when you watch that video,
when he starts caressing the leather inside the car,
it gets a little creepy. I had to fast forward to it. He was like, look at that.
That's fine. Italian leather. Oh yeah.
He didn't get that bad, but it got pretty bad.
But this fucking guy has got a bunch of them. Uh, uh,
Super Sport motors.com. Um,
at least he did as of I guess two years ago, two and a half years ago,
whenever you put this fucking video. But if I was going to buy one,
I would buy one off of this guy. Holy fucking shit.
I said he's got some beautiful cars, beautiful Cadillacs. Um, anyways,
let's plow ahead here. I think maybe it's time to, um,
maybe it's time to do a little like, oh, Trump gets sworn in this week.
You know, he gets fucking sworn in and, uh,
I would feel so much better about that guy. You know, it's,
it's not the racist people that he's putting in there, you know?
It's unsettling. Is that is, I mean, everybody's fucking racist, you know? Well,
that's not true. There's different degrees of it, but everybody has it.
Even people who are victims of it, they have it.
You look at another group of people, you, everybody's done that.
You look at a group of people, you think something like, oh, it's like this.
And then you go up there. Oh, it's actually like that. Wow.
Why did I think that? And it all was in your fucking head. You know?
I gotta do a bit about this.
I was driving down the street the other day by dude with a right driving down
the street, and I see this group of young kids, they school just let out. Right?
This is not a good sign right here.
I'm driving by a school right when the school got out and I'm caressing my
leather. Now I'm driving down the street and these kids are all outside like a,
it's right around the corner from where I'm playing drums. Here's my alibi.
I swear to God was playing drums around the corner and um,
it's one of those stores that sells like a, you know,
all the fucking snacks and shit that you eat afterwards and you get all fucking
wired.
So I'm driving by there and usually I get fucking annoyed because the kids are
fucking walking across the street.
They're not looking both ways and all that shit. And then I,
it takes me forever to make a fucking left or right hand turn or this day they
were all up on the sidewalk and I saw this movement.
I kind of glanced over and none of the kids were white and I saw this action.
I thought I was watching somebody getting the shit kicked out of them,
potentially getting, uh, beaten into a gang.
That's what my brain told me I was watching when I looked closer,
there was like seven kids standing around,
one kid looking at a fucking smartphone.
And then some other kids just sorta fucking, you know,
doing whatever running around in the background. And I was thinking,
why the fuck did I just think that, you know,
so before you fucking call all these assholes, all these races, assholes,
you know, you gotta get that shit out of your head. I was thinking,
why the fuck did I think that part of that is from the shit that I see on TV,
right? I think your brain just goes it. Once it gets stuffed down,
like how to make cereal, it just gets it down. Like, okay, just grab this,
fucking put this in here and then you've got fucking cereal. You know,
it connects to one, I want vision to this, this, this.
It's like a motive like survival, which works. But in that instant,
that didn't work, did it?
I went from that to a couple of fucking ice cube videos, whatever,
gangster rap videos or in my head, Shit that I saw in the news. Right?
They can't say there was fear. There was no fear.
I was just driving down the street and I looked and that's what I thought,
you know? But I kind of do that all the time. You know,
I read a Kid's book to my unborn daughter last night, right?
It's supposed to make them smarter. Right? And I was reading this kid's book,
and halfway through the book I realized I didn't,
I had no fucking idea what it was about. So maybe I'm just a moron.
I have no idea. But seeing, I want a flawed fucking person. I am a,
I can't judge, uh, I can only judge people so fucking harshly, right? Honestly,
I mean, I can trash your fucking Meryl Streep. I can go off in a Donald Trump,
but at the end of the day, I'm a fucking lunatic, right?
I read a kid's book and I couldn't figure out what it was about.
It was about this fucking caterpillar. All right? And they were like on day one,
at eight an apple on day two and eight,
two pears on day three at eight fucking three plumps. Right?
So right there, I'm like, all right, this is like reverse Christmas story.
Rather than go in like seven swans and swimming six skeezer lane.
It fucking starts with the fucking tree, the partridge in the pear tree.
Now it's moving up and it seems to me like it's about eating healthy and food
and, and counting. And then it gets up to like 12 or something.
And the thing just completely abandoned its fruit diet instead,
it had a fucking couple slices of pizza and ice cream and all this shit and in a
big stomachache. So then I was like, all right, this is about childhood obesity.
And um,
I actually lied in that and never dawned on me that it was about counting in.
Neo was like, I finished the book,
the thing turned into a butterfly and I said, I said the end.
And I looked at me and I said, I have no idea what that fucking book was about.
She laughs, she goes, it's about counting. I go,
it's not about not eating junk food because it ate all that fruit and everything
was fine. And then it, all that other shit.
And then it got sick and she was like crying laughing at me.
I don't know what that has to do with Trump,
but I really wish that idiot would get off of fucking Twitter.
But he's a fucking mess. He said about China, it's time to take the gloves off.
He, he, he's doing that George Bush thing where you talk about other countries,
like you're trying to psych somebody out before a bar fight and nothing gets
people more excited. Get that, gets more ons excited.
Like that's tough. Tart, right. If fucking idiots.
He's like trash in SNL cause they're doing sketches about them. It's just like,
I don't, I don't, I don't, he cannot be running his Twitter account.
There's no way he's this fucking sensitive, um,
or has the time to do this. Shouldn't he be addressing it?
My worst fear is that he's going to become president and just deregulate
everything so he can build a golf course or wherever the fuck he wants to. Like,
that's really, that's his idea of making it great again. I,
I hope I'm fucking wrong. I have no idea. Um,
having said all of that, still as much as he's a nightmare,
unbelievably unbelievable joy watching Hillary Lewis. Oh, I love seeing, yeah,
pack you bags. Okay. Pack you bags there. Fucking,
yeah. Saying all right, let's, let's, let's continue on. Alright, let's, uh,
them off the fucking rails here. All right. 42 minutes. Can we, uh,
can we read these lists to advertise and they'll do your questions for the week?
Um, all right. Helix, Helix. Hey, by the way, why don't you guys send those in?
Send in your,
I looked at this thought it was this way and then it was another way,
but nobody heard me say it. So everybody thinks I'm a great guy.
And that goes for non whities too.
Cause I know you're looking at us or some other group of people,
Koreans or some shit or whatever yet. I know you're thinking something.
All right. Hallux. Helix. All right. You're unique. And I actually,
you know, as much as I'm, I'm not really joking around about this shit,
but I think that people have to be able to say that they have those fucking
thoughts. I mean, this fucking, uh,
progressive left thing where you have to act like you're just walking around
going, I don't see color. I don't care if you're black, white,
green or purple. And it's all of those, all of that fucking sing songs,
Horse Shit. Um, even those people, even those people,
like you get them in the wrong situation and the fear comes up,
they're going to think something fucked up. They're gonna. Um, alright.
So if you have any of those stories I want to hear,
I want to hear them and then I'll try to, I'll,
I'll try to guess why you think that way. Okay.
So I'm guessing with mine it's, uh,
the news and all the gangster rap videos that I used to watch and I'm,
I'm old. So that was back when you could actually have a gun in the video.
And then also, I've,
I think I've watched too many of those life on the inside prison things,
you know what I mean?
All of those things where you just look at it and go and like,
I would last 15 seconds in there.
I've watched all those ones about gangs.
I've watched the ones about motorcycle gangs. I,
it's probably my, uh, my intake of, of, of television and youtube videos.
I watched videos of people's sucker punching people. Um, bully fails.
I watch a lot of violence. Yeah, that's it.
Maybe that's what it is. Alright. Hell, helix a, you're unique. You know,
walk like anyone else talk lot to anyone else. Shit, whack.
Anyone else asleep like anyone else? So why is your mattress one size fits all?
Because it truly customized mattress will cost you five to 10,000 bucks until
now. Go to helix,
sleep.com answer a few simple questions and they'll run a three d biomechanical
model of your body. And how will they do that?
Through the proprietary algorithms they've developed with the help of the
world's leading IR Ego, nomics and biomechanics experts, the results,
they build a fucking robot to take your place. But in the meantime,
you sleep on the most comfortable mattress you've ever slept on.
Helen's customers report a 30% improvement in overall sleep quality and for
couples, they customize each side of the mattress.
Your mattress arrives at a door at your door in about a week and shipping is
100% free.
That's why everyone from GQ magazine to Forbes are all talking about helix
sleep. You have 100 nights to try it out. If you don't like it,
they'll pick it up for free and give you 100% refund.
No questions asked. Dude,
I would dress like I'm fuck fucking beekeeper when I picked that thing up.
Go to helix, sleep.com/burn get $50 off your order.
That's helic sleep.com/bar
what
you're like, say like sleep.com/bar all right, lastly, but not leastly,
stamps.com you know one great resolution you can make for the new year.
Maximize every minute and every dollar for your small business.
I know no easy way to do that. Hey Lee,
stamps.com stamps.com is the better way to get postage.
Just use what you already have, your computer, your printer,
and your fucking fingers to get official us postage for any package.
Your letter. Then the mail man picks it up the mail man.
Everything you would do at the post office,
you can do right from your desk and at a fraction of the cost of one of those
expensive postage meters. I use stamps.com so whenever I send out my posters,
you know whenever I'm whoring myself out at the end of the show,
you know what I wanna fucking shake hands that have been sneezed into right now.
Sign up for stamps.com and use my promo code [inaudible] for this special offer,
four week trial plus $110 bonus offer that includes the posts include including
postage and digital stale scale. Go to stamps.com before you do anything else,
click on the
microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinburrthatstamps.com enter bar. Oh right.
That is it.
Okay.
All right, let's read some of the questions here for the weekend.
Then I can get the full Gatty. All right, team relocating.
Dear Billy Brady balls,
my NFL team I rooted for over 20 years is moving to La parenthesis.
Chargers. What teams should I root for? Patriots are out of the question.
Thanks and fuck the spinals family. First of all, my condolences.
I remember, um,
Jesus almost 25 years ago when Robert Kraft first bought the team and,
uh, he was threatened at some point, maybe was in the, in the year 2000,
somewhere around then. He was fucking threatening to, uh,
move the team to Hartford if he didn't get his own stadium and shit. And um,
that really is one of the biggest, you know,
fuck overs by all of these sports leagues that they,
they get the cities that we have to pay for their fucking stadium.
Um,
that's a time when you need a union.
If you could just have a somehow have a union of all sports fans, it'd be like,
no, you fucking pay for it. He fucking pay for a new stadium. You can't.
You know what I mean? I go to the ice cream store.
I have to buy a new fucking store when they want a new store. They pay for it.
But the money they made off of ice cream,
like how much money do you have to make?
Do you know when I was in fucking Indianapolis,
those poor bastards that live out there. I don't know if this is still the case,
but when I went out there,
when they were putting that Lucas oil field deal together,
when they were already paying for that,
they still had not paid off the RCA dome or the Hoosier Dome,
whatever the fuck they called it.
They was still paying for that other one and this fucking can't make them buy
another one.
Um,
having said that, I, I guess I can't get mad at the spinalis family.
If everybody else is getting a new stadium and he wasn't able to blackmail San
Diego, you know what good for you, San Diego. Fuck him.
You want a new stadium once you pack your bags up and get the fuck outta here.
But you guys also kind of fucked up the way Cleveland did.
You can't buy one team of stadium and then tell the other guys to go fuck
themselves. That's like in Cleveland when they,
the Jake got built and then a,
whatever his fucking name was the fuck was that guy's name.
Everyone in Cleveland screaming at right now. Um,
who sounded exactly like a
George C. Scott? Exact same voice.
Um,
yeah, he wanted to stay at him. They were like, yeah, fuck you.
You can stay in that absolute fucking shit hole. And he and he left. See you.
It's not personal. She has business. Um,
why did I keep thinking good? Dell? I'm a patriots fan.
That's all they think when they think of a fucking asshole.
I just think Roger Goodell. Um, yeah, that sucks man.
So who should you vote for? You know what I do, I would say fuck the NFL.
If the Patriots ever left, I would just say fuck the NFL.
I'd be done with it and I would just pick a college team, um,
called football is to shit. Um, you know,
even though the athletes, college sports are great,
but the athletes get fucked over that they don't get paid.
The fact that they sell at $100,000 stadium and then fucking idiots. Oh.
And it's always non athletic people who say this school,
they get a free education. I'll do they like,
they have time to fucking go to class. You major in, in football,
there's too much money at stake in, in all these,
in all the nerds that don't like the jocks at the college level.
It's like if it wasn't for that football program,
you'd be going to science class in a fucking tent. Um,
100,000 people are not going to show up to what you look through a microscope.
Don't ever forget that. All right?
So why don't you fucking put on your lab coat and go figure out how to make a
better football cleats? Oh, Jesus. Bill,
it was no reason to go that hard was there.
Can't we have respect for all of the arts? Uh, Meryl Streep doesn't,
she doesn't respect mixed martial arts. Hey Meryl,
why don't you tell us what the arts are? [inaudible] Jesus Christ.
Because there's not a symphony behind it. You never listened to it?
Watch NFL film. That's art. The music they put
behind it. Why aren't [inaudible] wearing that? Wearing it, wearing it.
[inaudible]
why that? Why not? Why not buy it? All right. Movie foods, videos.
MMM. Hey, the ability egg whites, uh, saw this guys videos on youtube.
He makes food from different famous movies and Oh,
that's pretty cool. And this one,
he makes the big Kahuna Burger from pulp fiction, which is pretty basic,
but in others he does some cool ship shit from chef,
one of my favorite movies of the last few years.
And at Acha the cartoon,
I highly recommend checking a few of them out.
He makes a couple of sandwiches that would give your grill top some great use.
Ah, too. That's awesome. Thank you. Look at that. No question.
Just great information. I guess I never tell you guys you can also do that.
That's fucking cool as hell. I will definitely check that out.
I have been a cooking up a fucking storm.
Um, you know, cause we can't really go anywhere.
Every once in a while I'll take me out to the movies, which this weekend,
this past week I saw moonlight and I saw, uh,
hidden figures and I really like both for different beat, hidden figures,
big Hollywood movie, you know, totally did the job was great.
Uh, and then I saw moonlight, which was also great.
And my favorite part of that fucking movie, No, I'm not ruin it.
No spoiler alert other unless you're into cars was,
which was annoying was there's this one part where this showing the main
character and then not showing his fucking car,
but you can tell it's a nice car.
I wanted to see the car and then they finally showed it. That was a,
I believe it was an 83 to 87 Oldsmobile cutlass.
And those were those great two doors that they had in the fucking eighties.
It was, you know, the, the Oldsmobile cutlass,
the fucking Chevy Monte Carlo in the Buick Regal.
Those fucking cars are the shit.
And I know a lot of those southern guys redo them and they put the big tires on
them. I don't like the big tires on them, but that's another one. Um,
that's sort of the pot. Poor man's fucking Eldorado. But I loved those in, uh,
some of the funniest
guys I knew when I was growing up, had those fucking cars.
Just anybody who had a car like was a fucking was,
it was a good shit as they say in Massachusetts, you know,
and slash a little bit shady, probably dealing a little bit of weed.
Maybe you had a fight last night. Those are all those guys.
They go into a bar and within 10 minutes they eyeball and somebody and then they
got to take the chain off cause they're going to get, do a fight.
Remember that in the 80s,
don't take your fucking chain off with dog and tonight.
Okay.
I think the change coming back, I think it's making a comeback. Um,
anyways, really enjoyed both of those movies. Uh, moonlight. I really fucking,
that was a classic just independent movie where it was like a,
it didn't fucking lead you around to the by the nose. Like,
and here's the next one and here's the next point.
You then is the next plot point. Um, really good movie. Alright.
Uh, Putin, Russian hacking. All right.
This guy's writing about Russian hacking and he start look, is that we started,
okay.
This guy started his fucking,
he just started his fucking a his email to me with, look,
he's already wagging his finger at me. Jesus Christ. Dude, relax.
He says, look,
international politics between two countries with enough news to destroy the
earth 10 times over is no laughing matter. Oh,
am I not supposed to joke about it?
How come you aren't all over this orange clown?
Okay,
all right. I don't want to stand with this. Do you want jokes about it? Sure.
Clinton was no prize.
But you're willing to give Putin and an out now gangster a pass.
Well, I don't remember him running for president of the United States.
What are you talking about?
What kind of world is going to be there for your new child? Oh,
shut the fuck up. Yeah. Gee,
I fucking hate when people will in your world is going to be there for your kid.
This same world that was there when I was a kid, progressively getting worse.
Mike, what? What is your fucking solution? There's no solution to this shit.
You got 7 billion people.
I'll run in and fucking 200 million different directions.
It's a shit show. All right. The second we weren't one tribe. It, it was over.
It's over second. There was two tribes.
It was fucking over whenever we started out. Right.
Let's just say they, I, I don't, I don't subscribe that there was a fucking,
and Adam and eve,
I think there was a pond and there was a bunch of us that came out as something
quarter that Neil degrasse Tyson. It was the fucking trees.
Other people say it was the fucking ocean. Whatever the fuck it was.
There was a bunch of,
but you can't have a man and a woman bagging and then their kids fucking without
having major problems. All right,
well maybe that's why cavemen look like they should.
Yeah,
I have. No,
but whenever we all weren't sort of cohabitating together,
but you know what happened is then as we came along, there was no language.
It was just, oh no, that shit. Of course it was going to be fucking arguments.
Everybody grunting and groaning, you know, I have no idea.
Like we were fucked. This thing was fucked from day one. Okay.
And I've gone down the rabbit hole of trying to fucking give a shit and trying
to, you know,
I don't get people to listen to my opinion,
which probably has 0.1% of 1% of the information that I need to actually make an
even remotely informed opinion. You know what I mean?
Look at all those guys on TV who do it for a fucking living from,
from Bill Maher to bill O'Reilly. Okay. Even those guys,
as much as they pay attention are severely handicapped by the fact that they
cannot look at tox top secret documents
to kind of connect the dots. All you can do is watch the fucking news,
read newspapers and try to figure out which ones seems to be sort of making
sense with what the fuck you're thinking. That's the best you can do, sir.
So I don't know what you want for me, but I'll continue reading this. Um,
this isn't like telling jokes to a few middle millennials in a strip mall.
It's not funny that Trump and his swamp full of white racist,
rich men are robbing us blind. Uh,
I agree with that.
But you realize that Hillary Clinton in 2008, after the banks went under,
uh, went and gave them a speech and said, don't worry, I got you guys.
Those aren't those the same rich, racist white people.
You know. Isn't that the same upper 1%, you know,
that you're talking about here? Uh, just saying they are, you know,
by the way that the upper 1%, no matter who wins, they win. You understand that,
right? The job pays 500 grand a year. It takes 100 million to get. Okay.
And then they owe these cons favors that got them in office.
They push it through, they deregulate stuff, they look the other way,
they granted government contracts, all of that shit.
And then once they're done being president, you'll watch with Obama,
he's going to make a fuck load of money going around. Air Quote,
giving speeches, 200,
300 grand a night to the exact same fucking people that put them in office.
That's just them washing their bribe money. People with blue ties,
red ties, red panties, blue panties.
They all fucking do it except for Jimmy Carter. As far as I can tell,
he stopped being president and started going around building houses for poor
people.
Everybody else sits around waiting for their fucking library to be built. Oh,
my soapbox. Give me a golden globe. All right.
Just saying they are both bad is really dropping the ball. No, it isn't.
You have your head in the fucking sand. That's what it is.
You just have your head in the fucking sand. Um,
I'm from New Jersey and no,
several contractors who were shorted by Trump and couldn't afford to sue.
Right.
And I worked in Atlantic city and he had a couple of casinos go under and they
got paid dimes on the dollar. I know how that works. He's a real asshole.
That doesn't give a shit about the little guy. He's got the track record. Okay.
Okay. And you're saying Hillary Clinton gives a shit about the little guy,
Hillary Clinton, who only swings by the little guy whenever she needs votes.
It spends the rest of the time on fucking Martha's vineyard in her zillion
dollar fucking house that she can somehow afford when her husband is only made
fucking at the most 500 grand a year.
She got paid as a senator. What does that make? 175 grand a year?
They're making less money than some of the fucking top comedians in the fucking
world. Yet there were $200 billion. How do you do that?
How do you do that legally, sir, tell me.
Tell me how you do that. Cause you fucking crooked.
Alright, so there you go. And here's the thing about Russia spying on us.
Fucking relax. We're doing it to them too.
Jesus Christ. They've shot up planes out of the sky.
A spine on a we spy on each other. Apps a fucking Lilly [inaudible].
Okay.
You know, that's, that's what we do. Every fucking thing that they're doing,
we're doing. They fucking with elections. We fuck with the elections.
They fucking with people in power,
putting people in power that shouldn't be in power. We do that.
They invade countries. We invade countries. They think they're right.
We think we're right. At the end of the day,
there's you and me sitting in fucking Russia, regular fucking people.
All right? That's it.
It's just the people up top that gets you all fucking stirred up. You know,
I'm telling you, they get y'all fucking steak gotta get ya.
[inaudible] I don't listen to any of it. I don't.
I just sit and I drink scotch and I drink myself into a stupor and I stare at
the wall, you know, and I try to figure out why.
I looked at three non white kids looking at an iPhone and stuff that someone was
getting beaten into a gang. When I solve that first,
then I'm going to move on to trying to solve the world problems. When I fall,
when I solve the problems in the fucking globe, that is my giant fucking head.
I'll move onto that. And You sir,
if you're really looking for somebody to solve the world problems,
you should probably look beyond a comedian doing a podcast where he says count
every other word and also says how uninformed he is. Okay.
So you know that you'd go agree to disagree. But you know,
if you want Meryl Streep and fucking a fucking Billy freckled hands to solve the
world's problems, I think you were in trouble. Anybody can give the lip service.
It'd be like, I think that's absolutely deplorable of Blah a blah.
I didn't vote for the fucking guy. Stop wagging your finger at me. All right.
All right. Plants in the house. Hey, the Billy ficus.
Uh,
I want you to know how I want to know how you feel about having plants in the
house. Uh, growing up we always had plants and CACTI in our house.
I think they bring a lot of life and color to a room and it's fun to water and
take care of them.
I know some people who would never have any plants saying that they bring dirt
and bugs in the house. I tell them that it's because they don't take care of,
maintain them.
You could say the same thing about a dog saying they shouldn't bring fleas into
the house, but obviously that student neglecting and taking care of the dog.
So do you have any plants in your home? Do you have any and you're home now? Oh,
do you like having plants in your home?
Do you have any home plants in your home now? Um,
ps is a total NFL bandwagon fan. I'm calling Green Bay to win it all.
Uh, all right. Um, no I don't like plants in the house.
Um,
I had a plant in my house one time a long time ago when I was a complete loner
and I, my apartment looked like I was in the witness protection program.
I was seeing this woman and she got me a plant and immediately I was just like,
Whoa, way, this relationship is moving too fast.
And what she was trying to do was to get me to open up.
And I remember she got me this plant and uh,
then I had to fucking water it and uh, I kinda liked it,
but then I'd go on the road and I would come back and it would be near death,
just like, you know, hang it down, you know, staring at his fucking toes.
And then I would nurse it back to fucking health and I would have ended up
having anxiety and then one day it finally died and I felt this just ridiculous
failure. Um,
yeah.
And it was a metaphor for the whole fact. You're on the road so much,
you can't sustain relationships. You can't even keep a plant alive.
How are you going to keep a relationship or a kill labs?
It was a horrible fucking experience. So, um,
I don't mind have it in my house if they are like growing like Bazell or fucking
rosemary or some shit somebody can eat, you know,
I'm selfish when it comes to plants.
Like we've got a bunch of plants around the house.
I don't give a fuck about them. I'm like, yeah,
why don't we dig these up and put in some fucking avocado trees, some oranges,
you know, something that we can eat slash throw it Zombie someday.
What do you say?
Plus having trees that grow fruit in your yard is a great way to figure out
who's your friend and who isn't your friend.
Especially during the apocalypse when people come over your fence and try to
steal your food,
they'll go to the food like moths to a light and then you can be on your roof
and you can pick them off with your fucking,
with whatever fucking weapon you have. Right? I'd go with the bow and arrow.
It's nice and quiet. Right to the neck
was the one that was the water. I mean the blood gushing out of their fucking,
what the fuck? Whatever you call it. The fucking artery there. All right.
Plants in the house already read that one. Here's the last one.
Hey Billy Bitch tits. Jesus.
I'm a lady and I listen to your podcast religiously.
I'm 29 years old and I've had since I moved out of my parents' house when I was
18 I have a history of anxiety and depression.
I found that in addition to taking medicine,
living with people really keeps me in check. Uh,
in two weeks I'm going to be moving into my own apartment and living by myself
with my dog. Oh, it's fucking awesome. That's the best.
I love living alone by the dog too. That would've been tremendous. Of course,
it would have died like the fucking plant. Uh, right now I live with two guys.
The three of us are super close,
but we've lived together for three years and it's time for us to move out of the
frat house and into our own places.
I'm nervous about living by myself because I'm scared that I'm going to isolate
myself and fall back into a cycle of depression again. I live in Indy,
so the weather is shit right now, which doesn't help in the spring and summer.
I play intramural sports, football and volleyball.
I'm very much a guy's girl and I don't have very many girlfriends.
I don't ever have a ladies night.
I'd rather sit at a bar with a beer and watch football or college basketball.
I hate dating. I am straight though. The gay people hate dating.
I don't know.
I would love to get your advice for a lady like me moving in her own apartment
for the very first time.
What would you suggest I do to stay social and not sit at home alone?
Watching the Indiana Hoosiers and downing cores light a PS.
Tell me I said hi and best of luck to you and me on the new year. New Baby.
Thanks. And Go fuck yourself. Um, oh boy. You're asking a fucking loner.
I love when I finally didn't have to have roommates and I lived alone.
I fucking loved it. I loved it. I talked to myself,
I talked to the TV. I had a great fucking time. Um,
and I guess I was,
I had a level of depression there that I wasn't really aware of. Um,
well, don't you get enough sort of interaction with the springtime?
You play intramural sports, football, volleyball. Okay. So it's the wintertime.
Um, I don't know. You want to go sledding?
I'm trying to think what the fuck he can do.
Is there a adult league snowball fight thing you can get involved in?
There's gotta be something that you could do if you're into sports.
Why don't you just join a fantasy league with some of your friends?
Um,
but I, I think what you are is,
I think you're a sweetheart and you're a relationship person.
You're just afraid to do it. So, uh,
that's why you like having roommates. You don't like being alone.
I'm totally guessing here, by the way. I don't fucking know you, but I, I think,
uh, I think it's time to give Dayton a try. You know,
I would do that. Maybe you're afraid of doing that. I would.
I think this seems like you need to face a fear and look at this living alone as
an opportunity thing and that this is the next logical step to find in the
person you want to be with in life, if that's what you're looking for.
So I would, um, embrace living alone and I'll fucking awesome that is.
And uh, decorate your apartment. Don't do what I did, you know,
have some color in their hair and all that type of shit. Something upbeat.
Um,
okay.
And, uh, I would become social.
I would have people over to your place if, I don't know if you cook,
this is zillion things you could do. You just have to make the effort. Um,
I don't know why you don't have many girlfriends,
but it sounds like you do have some girlfriends,
so you only need a couple of friends.
I would open up to your friends rather than some psycho on a podcast.
Not saying this was a bad move, but it's a nice step. I would open up to them,
just say, listen, I'm prone to depression.
So I'm worried that when I live alone that I'm going to become depressed.
You know, if you'd like to swing by and watch a game with me, blah, blah, blah,
blah, blah, I would do that.
I would be open and honest and maybe go talk to somebody about your depression.
Um, so you don't go down that fucking rabbit hole,
but it's great that you know that you're depressed and that you need to do
something about it so that you're way ahead of the game as opposed to where I
was, where I didn't know I was depressed and I fucking a
wow.
I don't know. It made a lot of stupid fucking moves for a long time. All right.
That's the podcast for this week. Uh, thank you so much for listening and, uh,
I'll post that video of that Cadillac. Eldorado it's fucking beautiful.
All right. Go fuck yourselves and I'll talk to you on Thursday.